let's say i have an equilateral triangle
where the length of each side is 14.
so this is an equilateral triangle all
of the sides have length 14 and inside
that i have another equilateral triangle
right over here where the length of each
of the sides is four and what i'm
curious about is the area of the region
let me color this in a different color
is the area of the region that i'm
shading in right here so it's the area
inside the larger equilateral triangle
but outside of the smaller
equilateral triangle so let's think
about how we would do this i encourage
you to pause this and try this on your
own
well the shaded area shaded
area is going to be equal to the
large equilateral triangles area so
large
equilateral
triangle
area
minus the area of the small equilateral
triangle
minus
the small
equilateral triangle area so we just
have to figure out what the area of each
of these equilateral triangles are
and so
to do it we remember that the area of a
triangle is equal to area of a triangle
is equal to one-half
base times height but how do we figure
out the height of an equilateral
triangle so for example if i have an
equilateral triangle like this let me
draw it big so i can dissect it a little
bit
so i have an equal round trying an
equilateral triangle like this the
length of each of the sides
are s and i always have to reprove it
for myself just because i always forget
the formula we remember that the angles
are 60 degrees 60 degrees and 60 degrees
they're all equal and what i like to do
to find out the area of this in order to
figure out the height is i drop an
altitude so i drop an altitude just like
here and it would split the side into i
know it doesn't look like it perfectly
because i didn't draw it to scale but it
would split it into
it would form these right angles and
what's neat about this is i've now split
my my equilateral triangle into 2
30. 30 60 90 triangles 30
60 90 triangles and that's useful
because i know the ratio of the sides of
a 30-60-90 triangle if this is s and
i've just split this into this orange
section this orange section right over
here is going to be s
over 2 this is also going to be s over 2
right over here they obviously add up to
s and then we know from 30 60 90
triangles that the side opposite the 60
degree side is square to 3 times the
shortest side so this altitude right
over here this altitude is going to be
square root of 3
s
over 2.
and now we can figure out a generalized
formula for the area of an equilateral
triangle it's going to be equal to
one half times the base well the base is
going to be s
so the base is
s
and the height is square root of 3 s
over 2.
square root of 3 square root of 3
s
over 2. and so this will simplify to
let's see we have in the numerator we
have a square root of 3
s squared
over 4
over 4. and now we can apply this to
figure out the areas of each of these
triangles so this is going to be equal
to the area of the larger triangle is
going to be square root of 3
over 4 times 14 squared
and the area of the smaller triangle is
going to be
squared 3 over 4 times 4 squared and
let's see we could factor out a square
root of 3 over 4 so this is going to be
equal to
square root of 3 over 4 times
14 squared
14 squared minus 4 squared
minus 4 squared which of course we know
this to be is 16. but now let's actually
evaluate this to actually get a number
here and i could try to simplify it by
hand but instead let me actually just
get my get my actually let's just let's
just simplify it by hand first so in
case you haven't memorized your 14 times
tables we could just work that out 14
times 14 4 times 14
4 times 4 is 16
and then carry the 1 4 times 4 is what a
4 plus 1 so it's 56 and you put a 0
right there because we're multiplying by
10 now 10 times 14 is 140
and so this is 196. so this is equal to
this is equal to square root of 3 over 4
times 196
minus 16
minus 16 which is equal to
180 so this right over here is equal to
and 180 is divisible by 4. so this is
going to be equal to the square root of
times let's see 180 divided by 4 is
going to be 45
so it's going to be 45
square roots of 3. did i do that right
180 divided by 4 times 45 is 160 plus 20
is exactly 180. so it's 45 square roots
of 3 and if i wanted to get an
approximate answer as a decimal so let
me get my calculator out so
let's go 45
times the square root of 3
would get us to 77 if i wanted to round
to the nearest hundred say that's 77.94
so this is approximately equal to
77.94 square units the area of the
shaded region